florida school district cancels real
history as an anti-crt censorship spread
the day after the florida state senate
education committee passed the bill
banning public schools and private
businesses from making people real feel
discomfort when learning about us racial
history a school district in central
florida canceled a teacher training
seminar about the civil rights movement
that had been months into planning j
michael butler history professor at
flagler college in saint augustine
planned three presentations covering
historic milestones like the brown
versus board of education decision the
march on washington the integration of
the university of mississippi and
montgomery bus boycott to butler this
was not just the culmination of
florida's year-long demonetization
of so-called critical race theory but
also the realization of something he
warned his students about years ago when
our former president used the term fake
news i told my class to be aware of
what's coming next and that's fake
history if there's a topic that can be
censored today that means there's a
precedent for the censoring of any topic
in any state moving forward and that
should scare all teachers what are your
thoughts on that
well there's a lot to unpack there i
start out by saying this idea that
critical race theory and history is the
same thing is a lie that is completely
dishonest critical race theory is a
theory
history is about facts so we know for
example that there was slavery in
america that is a fact
a sad fact is that there is also
segregation after slavery there was jim
crow laws there was all kinds of racist
policies that have fortunately changed
after the civil rights movement and now
i do believe
people do have equal opportunities here
now
say critical race theory it's a theory
based on marxism but basically instead
of a class conflict and class as your
identity group
it splits people into identity groups
based on race so it says no matter what
your background is and no matter who
your parents are if you're born white
you're an oppressor
if you're born black you're oppressed
and that's no that's not that's the
opposite of what america is based on
that's the opposite of our values the
reason why so many people come here of
all races from all over the world is
because it is
the only place in the world really that
you can come and you can reinvent
yourself and you can pursue what you
want to do in many other countries
including where i used to live in
eastern europe you're kind of born into
a certain family and it limits your
opportunities in some way it limits what
you could do and so
i think critical race theory it's
dangerous in a diverse society as we
have florida is a very diverse state so
to be segregating kids and telling kids
that are like five to eight years old
like saying that basically making them
feel that they're responsible for
historical injustices
is ridiculous it's dangerous it causes
divisions when we already have a pretty
divided society we don't want to make
that worse um and i should add that
florida law requires all public schools
to teach facts about history including
african-american history that's in the
law it says like there's a statute on
teaching african-american history and
what has to be in it and so there are
standards first amendment rights apply
to people they don't apply to the
government schools are part of the
government i mean public schools so they
have to teach a certain curriculum and
that curriculum is prescribed by state
law it includes facts it includes facts
about the holocaust it includes facts
about slavery you cannot deviate from
those facts and give your own personal
opinions about it based on your ideology
you have to teach what the standards are
right and so this is number one i don't
like this framing of the whole article
um
and number two you know
telling parents that their concerns are
not real that crt isn't really being
taught in schools or that they're just
racists maybe and they don't want kids
to learn real history this isn't
effective we saw what happened in the
virginia governor's race virginia went
for biden by 10 points
a republican won by two points 12 point
swing in one year because of this issue
in part education was the big issue
because parents of all races by the way
were seeing what their kids are being
taught
and they were horrified by it they were
shocked by it i mean like and it makes
sense because
you know it's it's the absolute opposite
of factual history at the end of the day
like to teach that america is founded on
racism and this kind of stuff
by the way tyler what is the definition
of racism just racist type in racist
definition i'm curious to know what
comes up
and pull it up on duckduckgo and pull it
up on google uh
make it right there to the left yeah if
you make it a little bigger okay
adjective now a person who's prejudiced
go to the top right against or
antagonistic toward people on the basis
of their membership in a particular
racial or ethnic group typically one
that is a minority or marginalized he
has been targeted by vicious racist
online prejudice against or antagonistic
towards a person or people okay got it
uh can you go to duckduckgo and let you
see what it says on there so the duck
duck goes as a uh is a noun a person who
a person who believes a particular
particular race is superior to others so
your race is superior than somebody
else's i mean it's a completely
different definition than what's on
google you think in your race is
superior to others
okay so hitler thought his race was
superior to others that's historical
racism is a belief that groups of human
possesses
different behavioral traits
corresponding to inherited attributes
and can be divided based on the
superiority of one race over another
is that is that going on in america
today there are racist people okay in
america as there have been throughout
history there have been racists in
history you named one hitler but there
have been racists in america as well
that does not mean that society is
racist that doesn't mean that our entire
system is racist and needs to be
destroyed and rebuilt as something else
you know it means that we need to work
towards
marginalizing those racist voices like
you know a generation ago we had
governors in the south um who were
pro-segregation
who were supported the idea that black
people could not eat at the same lunch
counter as white people
fortunately we've gotten rid of that
that had to happen they had to be
marginalized from politics leaders like
this who would support these policies
but
at the end of the day
today you don't see that anymore
what you do see though is a different
kind of racism which is basically
teaching kids that they're responsible
for the crimes of their ancestors
um that's just wrong
and then
telling kids that they are oppressed or
that they're victims of a system based
on their race even if are not even if
they have the same opportunities as
anyone else and what critical race
theory is
it is
basically saying
that um
your race defines who you are and we
don't believe that i mean we believe
governor desantis believes that your
experiences your interests your
individuality defines who you are yeah
it's it's not like collectivism is toxic
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]